the haunting of hill house was genuinely
terrifying but spiritual follow-up the
haunting of bly manor is a slower but
still spooky burn with some major twists
so here's what you need to know about
what actually happened
this is the ending of the haunting of
bly manor explained
in the second to last episode of the
haunting of bly manor we finally learned
the truth about the lady of the lake
in a black and white flashback set in
1676
we learned that a widower the narrator
calls mr willoughby
lived in bly manor with his two
daughters prodita
and viola if the name viola looks
familiar
it's the name flora was etching on the
chapel floor in episode four
after the widower dies the daughters are
at risk of losing the estate and their
financial inheritance
women in that time had nothing
no present no future without a tie to a
man
the women have to pick a suitor but they
decide that bly manor must stay
in the family so viola invites a distant
wealthy cousin named arthur to the
estate
viola is out when arthur arrives so
perdita takes it upon herself to make
him feel welcome
and quickly falls for him but once viola
makes her dramatic return home
everything changes she had already
decided that arthur would be hers
not perditas and that they'd married to
save the estate
predita knowing what's at stake accepts
this keeping her love for arthur a
secret
viola and arthur have a daughter named
isabel and the household is happy for a
time
but viola then falls deathly ill with a
disease a local plague doctor refers to
as
the lung it is not the plague
oh thank god
but it is not good news she has the lung
after a series of failed treatments a
vicar visits to read from the book of
john as a right meant to ease viola's
journey into the afterlife
the vicar asks her to repeat the right
but viola refuses
denouncing god in the process a decision
pradeeta supports
[Music]
tell your god that i
do not go
viola somehow wills herself to survive
despite her severe illness
growing increasingly miserable and
increasingly jealous over the years of
her healthy sister pradita's friendship
with her husband arthur
one night with arthur away on business
purdita no longer able to bear the
burden of caring for her sister after
six grueling years decides to put an end
to her suffering
covering viola's mouth until she stops
breathing
after a period of grieving arthur
marries perdita but they find themselves
in a difficult financial situation
which puts a strain on their marriage
before she was killed
viola left her finest gowns and jewels
in a trunk for isabelle to remember her
by
and made arthur promise not to give the
key to the trunk to anyone but isabelle
desperate to fix their money problems
perdida on the six-year anniversary of
her sister's death in 1686
decides to go behind her husband's back
and opens the trunk holding viola's
riches
when predita opens the trunk viala's
spirit
kills her it's then revealed that after
viola's death
her spirit was trapped in a kind of
purgatory
she's stuck in her room filled with her
fancy belongings
but all she can do is sleep and pace the
floor the narrator reveals that this
purgatory is just a construct
and viola's spirit is in fact trapped
inside the trunk
waiting for isabel to one day open it up
predita opens it first and viola gets
her revenge
before returning to her purgatory to
sleep as arthur and isabel are leaving
the manor
arthur decides to throw the trunk in the
lake on the ground so his daughter won't
suffer the same fate as predita
viola is heartbroken but in a callback
to her refusing to succumb to her
disease
she determines to escape the trunk
with every ounce of her considerable
will as when she was sick
and against all probability viola
would not go at night and now free
viola leaves the lake and walks to the
manor regularly visiting her old home in
search of isabel
over and over killing anyone who gets in
her way
the manor is eventually used to
quarantine those with the plague
leaving many potential victims at
viola's disposal
anyone who dies on the manor's grounds
is left in purgatory
strange phenomenon that begins when vila
kills the plague doctor
over time viola and her victim's
memories begin to fade
and so do their faces one such victim is
a faceless boy
the same boy we see flora interact with
in episode six
we also learned that predita is the
faceless woman trapped in the attic with
no memory of who she was or how she died
per the narrator
viola suffers the same fate for
centuries endlessly searching the house
at night for isabel
but not knowing why in the final episode
of the series back in 1987
the lady of the lake who we now know is
viola attempts to drag
danny the au pair into the lake hannah
the housekeeper and a blind man or
spirit urges viola to let danny go
to no avail but once viola finds flora
she experiences faint memories of her
daughter laura pleads with her to let
danny go
and viola takes flora instead and heads
to the lake
believing she's isabel uncle henry who
we now know is actually flora's father
arrives at the manor and distracts viola
for a bit before getting choked
and briefly dying appearing as a spirit
he is later saved via cpr by owen the
cook
who arrived with jamie the gardener
danny's love interest
after they both dreamt that the
inhabitants of bly manor were in danger
meanwhile at the lake the spirit of
rebecca the children's former au pair
has flora recite it's you it's me
it's us and promises to feel her pain
for her by inhabiting her body
and tucking her away into a memory this
is a technique
another bly manor spirit rebecca's lover
peter quint
developed in an attempt to fully possess
the children and escape the fading
memories and face-fading fate of the
other spirit supply
this also happens to be the same phrase
viola once uttered
to baby isabel it is you
it is me it's us
according to the narrator danny without
understanding what she's really saying
feels compelled to say the same phrase
she heard the children recite with peter
and rebecca
in an attempt to save flora with safely
dream hopping as viola walks her into
the water
dany's gambit works and viola's curse on
bly manor is finally lifted
peter no longer inhabits miles and
rebecca no longer inhabits flora
the rest of the spirits are also set
free including hannah
however per the narrator a part of viola
is now trapped inside dany
since dany invited her in we even see
one of dany's eyes change from blue to
brown to signal the possession
the same thing that happened to miles
when he invited peter in
after the children move out of the manor
with henry to find a new home in the
united states
danny and jamie leave the manor too
while preparing to move out dany tells
jaime that she can feel
viola watching her she predicts that one
day
viola will take her but jamie decides to
take an optimistic approach
telling danny that she'll stick with her
until the fate she fears eventually
comes to pass
the couple moves in together spending
years blissfully in love
and opening their own flower shop in
vermont but over time dany begins seeing
viola's reflection
and at first she keeps it hidden from
jaime but knowing that she
only has a little time left she decides
to give her a promise ring
at this point in the story it's the 90s
so they can't legally marry
instead the ring symbolizes that danny
is ready to spend the rest of her life
with jamie
no matter how soon that life may end
after seeing viola's reflection in a
pitcher of water and then once more
while washing dishes at home
dany finally tells jamie that she feels
her time to become the lady of the lake
is coming
at one point viola's presence becomes
even stronger with dany feeling
possessed by her to the point where she
almost
kills jaime by pulling viola's signature
move and strangling her
knowing jamie's life is now at risk
danny travels to bly manor where she
allows herself to become the new
lady of the lake when jamie realizes
what's happening she tries to stop
danny but it's too late the magic phrase
doesn't work this time because now danny
is officially the lady of the lake
and she doesn't want jaime to sacrifice
herself for her
nor does she want to claim any new
victims though jamie is unable to
reunite with danny she keeps an
optimistic outlook
always trying to catch danny's
reflection in the water
of course it's not a haunting story
without a big twist
but this time it's a very sweet one the
haunting of bly manor begins with the
narrator telling her story to a couple
and the attendees of their wedding
rehearsal dinner in 2007
the narrator gets very emotional at the
end and hints that she's speaking from
personal experience
despite telling the story in third
person after the narrator finishes the
bride to be tells her that she thought
the story was made up
because it was too much of a coincidence
that her own middle name
happens to be flora at the wedding
reception the next day
it's finally revealed that the narrator
is actually jamie
and the bride is in fact flora
she looks at henry and flora dancing and
imagines them
as their younger selves and we then see
a shot of
young jamie she also spots miles and
owen together
and raises her glass at them so why
didn't flora and miles recognize
themselves from the story
well before danny took up residence at
the bottom of the lake
she and jamie learned from owen who is
now a chef in paris
that flora and miles have no memories of
their time at bly
another interpretation is that jaime's
story is just a story
an allegory about depression loss and
memory
and bly manor never really existed or it
did
just without all the ghosts
i expect if you were to fly to england
he would find no such place by that name
once jamie is back in her hotel room she
follows her routine of drawing a bath
and leaving water in the sink
hoping that dany's reflection will
appear she also leaves her hotel room
door ajar
in case her past love returns as she
falls asleep in front of the door
we see danny's hand on jamie's shoulder
wearing the ring
it's an unexplained moment and it could
be a dream or the show's creator adding
yet another layer of ambiguity and a nod
to the famously ambiguous ending of the
book it was largely based on
or perhaps love just finds a way
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one